hey youtubers is Charlie so there's new
flash arrow footage from the crossover
next week and it implies that Oliver is
going to learn that he really does have
a son in Central City so we are going to
be talking about some connor hawke here
because he's also supposed to show up on
legends of tomorrow so I'm gonna play
these two promo clips but fair warning
the quality is kind of janky these are
both rips but the important part is that
they give a big shout out to all of us
child so here we go so big flashing
warning lights going off Oliver actually
gets to meet his son but the real
question is is like what kind of story
are they gonna use them for in the
future because each season we get like a
little bit more like they're in season
two we learned that he existed season
three we got the teaser during the big
flash arrow crossover season four we get
to see him in person so what are they
gonna do in season five now say Oliver
were to take some parenting tips from
Malcolm Merlyn he probably gets shipped
off to the League of Assassins for
training not expecting that to happen
although a version of that did happen in
the comics if you remember way way back
in the comics during the big zero hour
event how Jordan became infused with
parallax turned into this giant super
villain in destroyed Coast City Oliver
Queen ended up trying to kill him and
his guilt led him to go to a special
monastery to try and try and wash away
his sins like oh my god I killed one of
my best friends later when he found out
about Connor
he sent Connor to live at that monastery
not quite the League of Assassins but
you get the idea just like you know
sending him away to quote/unquote
boarding school for superheroes now
because the TV shows exist in the real
world I'm not expecting that to happen
I'm expecting Oliver to try and have a
more normal relationship with his son
albeit from a distance so during these
TV shows flash arrow all these other
superhero shows you can kind of
demarcate them into different types of
stories you have like the superhero arc
where they're trying to defeat a villain
some big plan develop new technology
then you have the personal drama where's
the characters just being normal human
beings like you know you find people you
love you get in relationships with them
maybe you have a child at some point
maybe a mystery child my guess is that
if the child survives which I think that
it will it will just slowly move from
like the drama stories to the superhero
stories you can't have a superhero as a
dad
without his life of
affecting yours like there's no way
you're gonna have a normal life but as
he says the name of this child is
William it is not Connor the weird thing
that's going on though is that it does
sound like connor hawke is gonna be on
legends of tomorrow because the pitch
was is that at some point in the far
future Oliver Queen has fallen and
someone has been inspired to take up the
mantle so of course that would be Connor
Hawke but it sounds like on legends of
tomorrow that character will not be all
of our son what about this clip though
Oliver's child in Central City legends
of tomorrow is gonna address the the
Batman thing where it's like someone
must always wear the cowl
so we'll see some future green arrow for
those of you that have never read the
the Green Arrow comics Connor Hawke was
introduced in the mid 90s he got
rebooted for the new 52 then they
brought him back for convergence that
was DC's big event that was going on
while Marvel's Secret Wars was happening
usually when he shows up it's like the
typical you abandoned me daddy issues
type story
not at all like Damian Wayne and
Batman's relationship the funny thing
about Damian Wayne and Batman is it
seems like they have the most positive
father-son relationship of any superhero
team in the DC Universe right now his
prideful as Damian is and as withdrawn
as Batman's personality is you still get
that they love each other
I don't know necessarily that that type
of relationship would work well in
live-action I feel like it's amazing in
animation just because Damian Wayne is
such a cartoony over-the-top character
like that's why people love him so much
because of this really cool heritage
that he has in this very Deadpool lack
of care for his immediate situation like
he just he doesn't care about danger
he's just like whatever I'm Damian Wayne
so I don't think necessarily that arrow
would choose to go in that direction
with Oliver and any children that he
might have but plus his child seems like
it's still under the age of 10 at this
point just because so many things have
to happen before they bring Connor Hawke
on the show if they ever did decide to
do that on air I'm gonna wait a little
bit to do a separate Connor Hawke video
but if you guys want me to do that just
let me know in the comments people
always make Batman jokes about arrow
Thea queen is really like the Damian
Wayne character of that show right now
but when you really think about her
she's kind of like a Damian Wayne
character with the Mia Dearden speedy
name so she has elements of both of
those characters backstories like she
was resurrected in the Lazarus Pit like
Damian Wayne was she has this crazy
bloodlust and she has a fairly good
relationship with Oliver but here's my
big question for you guys given all the
things that they're doing with flash
arrow ledge
tomorrow this season would you ever want
to see connor hawke on the TV show like
do you think that the narrative would be
able to accommodate him or do you think
if they did bring him on then the other
big characters like Merlin or Black
Canary or anybody else really any of the
supporting characters would suffer just
because you only have a certain amount
of time in each episode so certain
characters won't get as much screen time
as others so that's one of the drawbacks
to having like a really large cast with
a lot of big characters you can only
develop a handful of characters each
season like a lot of people have been
asking about Laurel this season like
what is her story arc well she brought
back her sister but what's happening now
like we know what Sara's arc is gonna be
she's gonna go on legends of tomorrow be
the white canary it's very clear very
laid out but we really don't know what's
happening with Laurel right now Quentin
has a much bigger story arc than Laurel
has right now which also kind of makes
me think that he's marked for death he
and Diggle both they're like my two top
picks for who's gonna end up in that
grave Paul Blackthorne is an amazing
actor so it would suck if he left the
show but I feel like of all the
characters that you could lose without
losing the integrity of the show he's
he's one of the top picks like if he
left they just have less stories at the
police station but just a reminder next
week flash and arrow big crossover
episodes happening red tornado is coming
to Supergirl and Gotham is having its
midseason finale there's going to be a
special Batman V Superman trailer that's
gonna drop during that during the Gotham
episode on Monday so I'll be doing a
separate video for that too
be sure to subscribe to get everything
and actually we have a giveaway winner
too named Logan Creed you win the
reverse flash ring giveaway for this
week just be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact info I'll start a new
round of the giveaway whenever I post
that first episode of the flash next
week so there's been a whole bunch of
Marvel DC Star Wars trailers de2 posted
this week you can click here for the
legends of tomorrow trail all the flash
arrow stuff and you can click here for
the Captain America civil war trailer if
you haven't seen it yet thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight